I need to ask hi-art Geral what kind of [ __ ]
1 m height Mika My album Gal Won-jun Fresh,
real beauty of 4 to 5 Yeah,
so
3 seconds before that, take off your roof
You’ve been testing all the time
[music
] So there’s only one name Why Wow Art Dick
Yeah o How
old is your height
Camping fh Mon
Yes It’s a normal expression, so you have to open this up early in the evening to make the car go a little faster.
Yes r The long-lasting
difference is difficult
Sudden uh go wall uh ask Guitar denial
first downgrade It's UK uh Doojoon Kaga Sephoro Healing Kai
oo Why
[Music] The
candidate for the game proposal is Junyoung There is no work because it is open
No concern  Let's do it, since 2 sit like this, even the
real vocabulary is like this 5m centrifugal
these days, it's a little bit more of a
wake-up turn, I'd like to have a drink on that one screen
Go
or to see you, you - Ah ah yo yes The
member that takes the longest to prepare is strength
I'm starting now These days, I'm a member of the
public, these things happen quickly, and the preparation time is titled hero and member Juni
Yang, representative Chika, so it's ugly. I'm waking up today, but I'm
taking some time
.  And these days, the
buildings are a
little bit more
elegant these days, such as
a story  Wait a minute in the voting run by the votes of the current Inca in the Indicators Cup
.
So I did some research on Sumi Jo, but I said yes
oh
oh oh oh wait  Wait a minute,
I don't know much about worrying, but the room sounds like a mother's coming. These days, I'm sure I
check a lot of the cell's yo ah na a lot of principal in the future. Is it true?
Problem
[Music]
So what can I do with this because I’m not a grown-up member, I have to change the question of whether I can
do it Reel or break with memory He that Zard 3
Oh, golf sports aren’t exactly in the serialization column like this 10
Uhm 123
Yes I didn’t hear the plan  You will think
like this [Music] Boy, this is an idea, but it’s removed Yes
uh Subin Han vote Beom Gyu 3 standard Kai Ampere Ah yes
left per l Beneficial Ano is necessary and the concept is 3
zu But it comes up once of Coke.  So then 123
Ah Shuning Kaiju Motto Swordsmanship Han Pyo Habit Change Unpair Hyung Taiga is unreasonable at this time
Why should I do now Pica Legolas to catch Pica Legolas to come in 1 Why is the people
late?
That’s right,
I say that I have the power of ni, so I’ll throw it all away.